you've said that 10 7 is your favorite
poker hand to place that's still the
case and what aspect of it is that you
enjoy yeah so it's one of those viewer
discretion is advised like 10-7 I've
just noticed this throughout my life you
know it's a tendency thing that I've
been lucky with it so so that's just
sort of but it's not like I'm gonna look
at 10-7 and go oh wow you know I'm gonna
call it all in or anything like that
I'll play it in situations where it
makes sense but you know it's rare
because it's not a very good hand but is
there
some aspect of belief in the magic of
this hand manifests quality of play
so here's the thing it's you know poker
players some have said it's unlucky to
be superstitious but we're all a little
bit superstitious a little bit you know
and so I don't know maybe it is a case
where when I have 10-7 I feel somehow
energetically that you know I'm more
likely to catch something which may
actually make me more apt to be
aggressive and confident in the hand but
but you really shouldn't let yourself do
that like you're not supposed to fall in
love with any specific hands yeah but
you know uncertainty
is ruthless
and so you know the the fact that it's
uh
um a game of Statistics it
it can be too painful for the human
psychology so maybe you have to hold on
to certain superstitions